doctors in South Korea say a wounded
North Korean soldier whose dramatic
defection was all caught on video is now
conscious the United Nations released
new video from several security cameras
that show this daring escape he was
chased and then shot by fellow North
Korean soldiers then Tracy is in Beijing
with how the defector barely made it out
alive
Ben good morning again good morning this
is the first time in a decade that a
North Korean soldier has defected by
crossing the heavily-armed border with
the South in his escape looked like
something right out of a Hollywood movie
the extraordinary video begins with this
army Jeep racing down an empty road
inside the demilitarized zone between
North and South Korea North Korean
soldiers aware something is wrong run
from their checkpoints and begin to
chase their fleeing comrade the
defectors truck gets stuck and he then
literally runs for his life the other
soldiers follow an open fire shooting at
him approximately 40 times the defector
was racing across the military
demarcation line the official boundary
between the two countries inside the DMZ
the UN Command says North Korea's army
violated the 1953 Korean War armistice
in their pursuit of the fleeing soldier
the kPa violated the armistice agreement
by one firing weapons across the MDL and
two by actually crossing the MDL
temporarily you can see this North
Korean soldier briefly crosses the line
and then hurries back this heat-seeking
video then shows South Korean soldiers
dragging the lifeless body of the
defector to safety he was flown by
helicopter to a South Korean hospital
where doctors removed at least five
bullets from his body now doctors say
they found several parasites in the
soldiers body which gives you a sense of
how bad conditions are in North Korea
we've also been told that since he woke
up in the hospital he's apparently been
riveted by watching action movies and
American TV shows including CSI I'm glad
okay Ben Tracy and Beijing thank you